le match
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans par le
mcdo le magazine qui vous résume
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat avec à mes côtés
tiwanaku gentil beau bonjour organe est
notre invité cette semaine et amélie de
montchalin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député la république en marche de
l'essonne merci d'être avec nous et dans
l'actualité parlementaire cette semaine
il ya d'abord le budget c'est la mère
des batailles et elle est lancée le
projet de loi de finances 2010 9 a été
présenté lundi en conseil des ministres
le texte ensuite été défendu par le
gouvernement devant les commissions des
finances de l'assemblée et du sénat
6 milliards de baisses d'impôts pour les
ménages c'est le chiffre annoncé est
martelée par l'exécutif l'opposition de
gauche comme de droite le jugent
fallacieux libérer les entreprises pour
relancer la croissance et la philosophie
de la loi pacte ce texte économique
phare de la rentrée et examiné dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
depuis mardi
peut-il apporter à l'économie française
le nouveau souffle dont elle a besoin
les débats se sont en tout cas attendu
sur la question du relèvement des seuils
sociaux
et puis noir que le sénat ne digère pas
la chambre haute a repoussé cette
semaine à loix agriculture et
alimentation
motif le texte aggraverait les
difficultés des agriculteurs qu'elle est
pourtant censée soutenir notamment face
à la grande distribution
et on commence cette semaine avec le
budget qui entame son marathon
parlementaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la foulée de sa présentation en
conseil des ministres lundi matin les
deux ministres en charge du budget sont
venus le présenter devant les
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat en commission
gérald darmanin et bruno le maire vante
une baisse d'impôts de 6 milliards du
jamais vu depuis dix ans dit il faut
leur répond l'opposition
stéphanie de pierre hésitations sur le
prélèvement à la source croissance déjà
en perte de vitesse situation
internationale instable
ce deuxième budget du quinquennat macron
intervient dans une conjoncture
économique et politique beaucoup plus
compliqué que l'an dernier mais
l'exécutif veut montrer qu'il garde le
cap fixé par emmanuel macron notamment
sur la maîtrise des finances publiques
nous allons poursuivre ce rétablissement
des finances publiques
nous allons le faire avec beaucoup de
constance avec beaucoup de détermination
en baissant les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les ménages comme sur
les entreprises avec l'objectif de tenir
les engagements du président de la
république
5.2 dette publique en moins trois points
de dépenses publiques en moins et un
point d'impôt en moins d'ici la fin du
quinquennat ce projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 9 nous permet de tenir ce cap
après la hausse de la csg la grogne des
retraités le gouvernement cherche
surtout à rassurer les français
les ministres martèle que le pouvoir
d'achat augmentera en 2019 il annonce 6
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts la
droite contestent le calcul quand il ya
des baisses de cotisation d'un côté il y
à des augmentations de l'autre ces 6
milliards c'est de la monnaie de singe
ça n'existe pas tout ça c'était du
pipeau c'est de la communication une
fois de plus mais ça ne résiste pas à la
réalité des chiffres et nous allons nous
employer pendant tout le débat
budgétaire a démontré que ces 6
milliards de baisses de prélèvements
n'existent pas en réalité la pression
fiscale continuent au même rythme
qu'elle était sous françois hollande
les socialistes n'y crois pas non plus
ce qu'il ne dit pas c'est tout ce qui
est la baisse de pouvoir d'achat les
retraites non revaloriser les
allocations familiales pour toutes les
familles non revaloriser les allocations
logement pour toutes les familles ainsi
non revalorisé par exemple pour
l'allocation logement depuis 2010 est ça
représente en moyenne 160 euros de
pouvoir d'achat en moins
c'est là aussi quand vous sommet tout
c'est assez conséquent le ministre des
comptes publics
rétorque que c'est la plus forte
réduction d'impôt depuis la loi tepa
dès 2008 alors amélie de montchalin un
budget ce sont des chiffres mais c'est
aussi un message un message politique
quel est le message que le gouvernement
veut adresser aux français avec ce
budget 2010 9 d'abord c'est un message
de constance sa dernière on a voté au
parlement un budget sur cinq ans ce
n'était pas pour faire joli
c'était vraiment pour fixer un cap et
pour faire entrer l'intégralité du
projet que nous avons défendues pour la
campagne présidentielle puis
législatives dans un même dans un même
dream est mort à même budget sur cinq
ans pour vraiment nous tracer une
trajectoire
cette trajectoire elle est au fond assez
simple c'est qu'il nous faut recréer de
l'emploi en france
pas parce que c'est un slogan et parce
que si on à l'emploi on peut payer
retraites si on a de l'emploi on peut
payer l'assurance chômage peut payer
l'assurance maladie on peut réinsérer
des personnes éloignées de l'emploi vers
l'emploi et donc notre bataille c'est
celle de l'emploi du travail du travail
qui paye des entreprises qui peuvent
créer de l'emploi
c'est celle de redonner à notre pays des
fondements économiques solides investir
et créer des emplois pour faire ça il ya
des mesures dans ce budget 2010 9 qui
continue ce qu'on avait voté en 2018 et
qui renforce ce qu'on avait voté en 2018
par exemple on va dé retirer les charges
sociales sur les heures supplémentaires
ces 600 millions de charges que la
sécurité sociale ne mettra pas dans ses
caisses on va augmenter la prime
d'activité encore de 20 euros
c'est pour toutes les personnes qui
travaillent souvent à temps partiel ou
qui ont des petits salaires
20 euros de plus en 2018 la en octobre
20 euros de plus en 2019
c'est à nouveau vraiment un
investissement très fort on va aussi
continuer à rêver c'est la taxe
d'habitation pour les classes moyennes
ne soit pas surtout quand ils sont en
banlieue comme en essonne où comme elles
sont en zone périurbaine ou dans les
zones rurales cela on paye le plus de
taxe d'habitation
sa c 4 milliards d'euros qu'on a déjà
rendu en 2008 et on rajoute 4 milliards
en 2019
et puis ensuite il s'est dit sûr de
charges sociales c'est vraiment 4
milliards d'euros de plus qui seront sur
le compte en banque des français en 2010
9 par rapport à 2010 8 c 4 milliards
d'euros c'est parce que nous versons les
charges
quand vous faites la somme vous avez 8
milliards qui sont d'impôts qui sont
retirés
effectivement et des impôts qu'on
augmente et on les augmente en les
assumant pleinement ses les impôts sur
les cigarettes et c'est les impôts sur
le diesel et l'essence parce que ce sont
des mesures de santé publique
73 mille personnes meurent pas rond du
tabac et donc on a besoin d'avoir une
vraie politique
et puis on a ensuite la pollution et
l'écologie qui sont au coeur de ce
budget est donc 8 milliards qui baissent
plus 2 milliards c'était bien moins 6
milliards ensuite il ya un autre débat
question le succès incontesté par parle
monsieur qui dit que le gain de pouvoir
d'achat réel pour les français et 3
milliard à 2 3 milliards et demi alors
il parce qu'on parle pas la même chose
les impôts c'est ce qui rend dans les
caisses l'état en 2019 va se priver de 6
milliards d'euros de recettes que les
ménages payent avant le pouvoir d'achat
c'est quand vous comparez un revenu et
l'inflation
hélas les économistes vous dise et bien
qu en fait toute la somme de tout ce que
vous faites
effectivement pour les ménages ces trois
milliards et demi de plus c'est le plus
beau de points depuis dix ans
si on n'avait pas baissé les impôts de 6
milliards c'est pas plus trois et demi
qu'on aimerait c'est moins deux et demi
milliard donc c'est parce que nous
baissons les impôts de 6 milliards
d'euros que nous arrivons à ce que
pouvoir d'achat augmente de 3 milliards
et demi et donc trois milliards et demi
pouvoir lâche en plus c'est ce qu'on a
jamais fait depuis dix ans et s'est
permis par la plus baisse la plus forte
baisse d'impôts qu'on n'ait jamais fait
non plus depuis 10 ans donc cette mesure
là les gens vous disent déchiffrer ça
moi ce qui compte c'est le sens pourquoi
on fait ça on fait ça parce que dans
notre pays
oui on s'est engagé à baisser de 20
milliards les impôts pour les
entreprises et les ménages
et que quand vous regardez tout ce qu'on
a fait à la fin 2019 on a quasiment
atteint cet objectif en deux ans et
ensuite on s'est surtout engagé à ce que
notre pays retrouve des bases saines
nous n'avons pas de miracle sinon on
fait ce qu'on a fait depuis 40 ans c'est
qu'on donne de l'argent français on va
dire regardez votre consommation votre
pouvoir d'achat augmente mais les
finances et comment par de la dette
mais vous vous parlez de ces baisses
d'impôts 1 c'est d'ailleurs le message
que font passer le mil ministre depuis
qu'ils ont présenté ce budget est ce que
tous les français vont en voir la
couleur de ces baisses d'impôts là on
octobre tous les salariés de france ont
une augmentation de salaire parce qu'à
moins de charges pu s il ya plus de
cotisations maladie il ya plus de
cotisations chômage là en octobre 80 %
des français voient leur taxe
d'habitation diminuer la en octobre les
millions de français qui touche après
une activité et va passer de 130 euros à
150 euros
quand vous êtes au smic là on octobre en
novembre par dont l'allocation adulte
handicapé augmente donc
les résultats dont on parle c'est pas de
discours ce sont des choses qui arrivent
et les retraités maintenant les
retraités est ce que les gouvernements
ne fait pas peser trop d'effort sur ces
retraités les retraités c'est un sujet
qu'il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
prudence parce qu'on dit beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui ne sont pas
vraies notre but n'est pas d'opposer les
français les uns aux autres j'y reviens
les retraites sont payées par les gens
qui travaillent on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui augmenter les retraites
autant que l' on le voudrait bien sûr
que j'aimerais augmenter les retraites
beaucoup plus mais je ne peux on ne peut
pas le faire s'il ya plus de gens qui
travaillent vous savez au début du
quinquennat françois hollande les
retraites ils ont beaucoup augmenté
mais elles ont aussi amené à ce qu'on
ait cinq points de dette en plus donc
c'est qui c'est pas les français qui ont
financé ces mes enfants vos enfants nos
petits enfants qui paieront la facture
les retraités notre politique c'est
surtout d'améliorer leur vie quotidienne
d'améliorer les services
quand on travaille sur le reste à charge
que dès 2019 les prothèses auditives
coûteront 200 euros de moins pour chaque
oreille ça c'est du pouvoir d'achat
quand on travaille sur les services à la
personne pour que vous et les crédits
d'impôts et pas seulement des réductions
d'impôts
ces deux milliards d'euros qu'on a
permis de donner à des ménages modestes
et notamment des retraités modestes et
des d'homicide quand on travaille sur
les hôpitaux de proximité
on travaille pour un des sujet principal
d'inquiétude entre qui est l'accès à la
santé quand on travaille pour préparer
la dépendance on aide ces retraités qui
s'occupent de leurs parents à pouvoir
vivre
on aide les aidants comme on dit tout ça
ça rentre ensemble et moi le message aux
retraités que je leur envoyais c'est
bien sûr qu'il ya des sujets financiers
mais il ya surtout des sujets de service
public qui aujourd'hui n'existe plus
pour beaucoup de retraités et qu'on est
en train d'essayer de recréer au bon
endroit au juste prix et pour que ce
soit dans leur vie quotidienne des
services qu'on rapporte vous parliez de
la dette à l'instant je vous propose
d'écouter le sénateur centriste vincent
delahaye pour lui le gouvernement ne
fait pas assez d'efforts pour diminuer
la dépense publique on écoute on ne peut
pas toujours de maîtrise de dépenses
publiques en fait on ne maîtrise pas on
continue à l'augmenter de la dernier
l'année dernière ces 20 milliards de
plus cette année ses 25 milliards de
puces donc moi c'est des discours que je
ne peux pas entendre la sphère publique
ne cesse de prendre de l'ampleur
vous savez que en 1980 il y avait trois
millions deux cent mille fonctionnaires
pourquoi emploi public
par d'emplois publics aujourd'hui on est
à 5 millions six cent cinquante mille
donc on n'arrête pas d'augmenter en fait
on ne baisse jamais on a aujourd'hui une
situation financière qui est très
mauvaise l'état ne fait pas assez
d'efforts l'état ne devrait réduire ses
dépenses
elle ne les réduit pas et du coup on a
exactement le même scénario finalement
qu'au précédent quinquennat avec
hollande
on nous promettait en cinq ans le retour
à l'équilibré et on nous disait les
efforts on les fera à la fin a remis de
montchalin ce budget table sur un
déficit public de 2 8% l'an prochain la
dette atteindra 99 % du pib à la fin du
deuxième trimestre 2010 8 c'est ce que
vient d'annoncer l'insee pour 2019 vous
tablez sur 98 6 % de dette et sans les
privatisations il aurait peut-être
dépassé les 100% est ce que finalement
ce gouvernement ne fait pas comme ses
prédécesseurs à savoir laisser filer les
déficits pour financer des peintures à
court terme là j'ai plein de choses à
vous dire parce qu'on est vraiment dans
une histoire qui n'est pas la bonne
qui n'est pas vrai en 2018 est ce que
vous savez de combien augmenter la
dépense toute la dépense publique 0%
enfin en volume 0% en volume ce n'est
jamais arrivé
on va avoir pendant trois ans de suite
une dépense publique en volume qui va
augmenter de moins de 1%
ce n'est jamais arrivé on va avoir là un
déficit alors vous parlez de 2,8 pour
cent c'est un déficit qui comprend une
mesure qu'il mesure de transition qui
s'appelle la bascule du cic en baisse de
charge on va faire simple on demande aux
téléspectateurs au 1er janvier 2020 si
on ne changeait rien d'accord le niveau
de ces deux recettes et de dépenses fait
que les déficits c'est 1,9 pour cent 1
9% c'est le déficit qui sera celui dans
lequel on rendra je l'avais clés du
budget 2010 9 à la fin de l'année 1,9
pour cent c'est quand on est arrivé nous
ici en 2017
la cour des comptes nous expliquer qu'on
était à trois points 4 pour son déficit
on a réussi à passer en dessous de 3 et
là enfin 2019 on est à 1 9%
avoir trois années avec un déficit
inférieur à 3 %
ce n'est jamais arrivé depuis 20 ans et
donc ce que j'entends là quand on
explique les d'histoire l'état en 2019
afin de choses qu'il n'est jamais arrivé
il va faire avoir une cro une des
dépenses qui vont diminuer de 0 8% en
volume pendant ce temps là les
collectivités locales font plus 1 2
on est en train de nous raconter une
histoire qui n'est pas celle de nos
chiffres qui n'est pas celle de notre
budget on est en train de faire des
efforts très très très important mais
surtout ce qui compte c'est qu'on fait
des choix
quand je vous dis qu'on augmente après
une activité contenant qu'on investit
dans le travail qu'on investit dans
l'éducation ont fait des choix
il ya effectivement une réforme par
exemple du logement social il ya une
réforme dans les contrats aidés mais on
investit aujourd'hui massivement dans
l'enseignement on investit massivement
dans la justice la police l'armée enfin
1,7 milliard de plus pour notre armée
c'est la loi de programmation elle
s'applique donc cette histoire de nous
faire croire que les dépenses
augmenterait sans contrôle ce n'est
absolument pas ce que nous faisons et
surtout nous faisons des choix clairs
pour les français pour l'avenir pour
l'éducation et donc je pense que nous
aurons dans ce débat tout l'occasion
dans les mois qui viennent de montrer la
réalité ce qu'on fait on va continuer à
parler d'économie avec notre deuxième
thème l'impact
[Musique]
145 articles plus de 2600 amendant la
loi pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises
mastodonte législatif de cette rentrée
et examiné depuis mardi dans les cimes
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale
elle est censée redonner de l'allant à
une économie française en faisant sauter
ces verrous pour ses détracteurs au
contraire c'est un nouveau train de
déréglementation le résumé des débats
est signée mari la bat
c'est la pierre angulaire du projet de
loi par les seuils d'effectifs dans les
entreprises
en tout il existe 199 obligations liées
à ces seuils en france trop complexe
selon le gouvernement qui souhaite avec
l'article 6 ne conserver que trois
niveaux 11 50 et 250 salariés
bruno le maire fait alors heurté à
l'opposition qui souhaitait relever le
seuil intermédiaire vous êtes une
entreprise de bâtiment et travaux
publics de à 47 salariés
on vous commandent un collège une école
une crèche nous nous disons à ces
entrepreneurs
vous avez 5 ans si c'est uniquement pour
la durée de votre commande que vous
embauchez trois quatre cinq personnes
supplémentaires
franchissez le seuil de 5 ans vous ne
serez pas soumis aux obligations de ce
seuil
donc c'est une liberté qui leur est
donnée qui est considérable le
gouvernement espère ainsi générer une
économie pour les entreprises de près de
500 millions d'euros autre mesure
adoptée cette semaine la mise en place
d'un guichet unique électronique pour
créer son entreprise ou encore
l'obligation pour l'administration de
publier dans la presse les noms des
mauvais payeurs de fournisseurs je pense
qu'il nous faut aussi montrer que nous
sommes intraitables véritablement
intraitable sur certaines dérives
et pour cela et c'est assez rare que je
m'exprime ainsi je pense qu'il faut
frapper là où ça fait mal
il faut 20 ans pour construire une
réputation il faut parfois cinq minutes
pour la détruire
enfin un amendement concernant la
protection des conjoints d'artisans de
commerçants et agriculteurs a suscité
une vive émotion dans l'hémicycle je
vous remercie au nom de toutes ces
femmes qui travaillent pour leur mari et
qui quelquefois vivre à titre personnel
des situations épouvantables du fait
d'un divorce
donc c'est un moment de beaucoup
d'émotion que nous vivions dans
l'hémicycle je suis désolé
vous dire si c'est comme ça que je le
vis il a été adopté à l'unanimité par
les députés mais nonchalant vient de
voir un moment rare dans l'hémicycle ce
moment d'émotion qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
en fait ce qui est intéressant dans
cette loi c'est que on peut en parler ou
et de manière très technique
on peut aussi en parler sur le quotidien
des entrepreneurs cette loi en fait
c'est une loi sur les pme
c'est une loi sur ces millions de petits
patrons ces 140 milles pmc des
auto-entrepreneurs ces artisans qui
cherche à développer leur activité qui
voit là ont été confrontés à des tonnes
et des tonnes de normes de complexité et
à qui on essaie de donner de l'air en
disant voilà votre objectif notre
objectif c'est que vous puissiez grandir
c'est vous puissiez embaucher et
effectivement cette mesure qui consiste
à donner un statut aux conjoints des
entrepreneurs moi je viens d'une famille
d'agriculteurs
ma grand mère dit n'avoir jamais
travaillé moi sa petite fille je l' ai
toujours vu travailler mais elle n'a
jamais eu de statut et n'a jamais été
salarié n'a jamais été reconnue dans son
travail elle l'a toujours fait elle ne
vous dirai pas qu'elle n'a pas ne dis
pas qu elle a travaillé elle a considéré
qu'elle rendait service
eh bien je pense que notre société de
pouvoir leur donner un statut c'est
extrêmement c1 extrêmement important
message parce que ça montre bien que
notre société repose sur le travail et
qu'on valorise le travail dans la loi
pacte et des choses aussi extrêmement
importants qui vont venir sur le rôle
les entreprises le rôle dans la société
le rôle par rapport à l'environnement il
ya aussi rond l'a vu les seuils les
seuils c'est de dire quand vous avez 49
salariés vous avez l'impression que le
monde va changer si vous embaucher une
personne de plus ce sont des débats qui
dure depuis dix ans 30 ans moi j'ai
l'impression que je suis né en entendant
parler des seuils et d'entrepreneurs qui
me dit non sinon ailleurs d'énormes tous
ces débats là oui on essaye de débloquer
le pays bien sûr que c'est pas magique
mais pour beaucoup de ces patrons ces
choses qu'ils attendent moi j'ai fait
une réunion publique dans ma
circonscription et le retour c'est c'est
trop beau pour être vrai donc voilà ça
ce vote bien ce qui aura des débats
compliqués bien sûr que les mesures
qu'ils font pas l'unanimité on va en
votes que vous savez rarement à
l'unanimité mais sur des mesures comme
ça c'est la qualité nos débats c'est
aussi qu'on puisse créer les choses qui
sont d'intérêt général qui parle au
coeur du quotidien et qui montre que
l'action politique
elle a un vrai sens quand elle va
justement dans ce qui bloque le pays et
c'est ça qu'on fait dans la loi pas que
dans beaucoup d'autres lois aller
à la racine des problèmes sur le plan
politique le choix le gouvernement a
fait le choix d'inscrire cette loi en
priorité à la rentrée de l'assemblée
plutôt que la réforme constitutionnelle
alors que la croissance
on l'a vu tâtonne un peu est ce que
c'est le signe d'une inquiétude sur la
croissance et est ce que ce texte ait
vraiment de nature à relancer la
croissance en france faire venir on a
voté comme hier jeudi à bouger sur cinq
ans on prévoyait qu'en 2019 on ferait
avec 2 7% de croissance
on prévoit qu'en 2010 est au frais 1,7
pour cent de croissance l'insee
maintenant qu'on ne lit on va faire un 7
1 7
donc cette histoire de croissance qui se
dégonfle c'est cher c'est aussi un peu
fabriqué on a voté un 7 sur le
quinquennat on va faire un 7 sur catia
2017 été très bien tant mieux on est
exactement là où pensez être donc ya pas
de problème sur la croissance
en revanche on vient d'en parler si on
veut que notre pays retrouve des
capacités pour financer les retraites
pour financer l'assurance chômage pour
financer l'éducation pour investir dans
l'avenir il n'y a pas de miracle soit
c'est la dette soit c'est le travail
donc c'est essentiel et c'est
prioritaire qu'on essaie doit pacte
voter rapidement parce que débloquer la
capacité à créer des emplois à ce que
les entreprises grandissent et qu'elle
se développe c'est la priorité de toutes
nos batailles
c'est ça qu'on cherche et donc c'était
effectivement extrêmement important et
bien de le faire au plus vite
on va passer à la loi alimentation au
sénat rejeté sans être examiné
[Musique]
votée la semaine dernière à l'assemblée
nationale elle a été rejetée sans débat
mardi soir par les sénateurs ils
dénoncent le mépris de l'assemblée
nationale sur le travail du sénat et
accusent le gouvernement d'avoir poussé
à l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire
julie l'un et sandra cercueil une
discussion générale une question
préalable
et puis s'en va les sénateurs ont choisi
de refuser le débat pour la seconde
lecture du texte de la loi agriculture
et alimentation
je constate que la majorité sénatoriale
souhaite rejeté le texte
j'en prends règles je le regrette c'est
une posture politique que que je
regrette une majorité sénatoriale qui a
souhaité tapé du poing sur la table
après l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire qui devait permettre de
s'accorder sur une version du texte
commune aux députés et sénateurs
non seulement le texte qui nous est
transmis ne peut nous convenir
mais tout effort pour l'amendé serait
inutile puisque nous savons désormais au
terme de la cmp qu'aucun de nos apports
ne seraient repris on voit bien que tout
cela n'a pas de sens ou plutôt que tous
ceux qui ne vient pas d'un élu de la
république en marche et rejeter sans
aucune bienveillance
malgré leurs désaccords les sénateurs
les républicains centristes et
socialistes ont donc voté ensemble la
question préalable qui permet de rejeter
la totalité du texte au centre des
débats la question du revenu des
agriculteurs au sujet de la rémunération
des agriculteurs l'état refuse d'assumer
le rôle de régulateur de la puissance
publique
et pourtant ce serait une impérieuse
nécessité
ce projet de loi et sans saveur et ne
pose en aucun cas les bases d'un revenu
paysan alors que cet élément était la
priorité à la sortie des états généraux
de l'alimentation
les sénateurs ont annoncé la mise en
place d'un groupe de travail pour
évaluer les conséquences du projet de
loi et peut être saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
le texte sera adopté mardi prochain par
l'assemblée nationale qui aura le
dernier mot
ml non chalain sur la méthode est ce que
le rejet de ce texte par le sénat n'est
pas un mauvais signal est ce qu'il ya un
mépris du travail sénatorial comme on
dit les sénateurs alors moi sur la
méthode de parlementaires vous savez
dcmp qui échoue déco
ici en mixte paritaire qui n'aboutissent
pas si c'est le cas souvent c'est même
le cas très fréquemment
nous avons eu sur la loi logement une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive
là on n'est pas dans une cmp qui échoue
de manière traditionnelle les sénateurs
disent que le gouvernement a poussé à
l'échec de la scène alors je ne n'étais
pas dans cette cmp donc je ne peux pas
vous dire voilà les cmp se font entre
parlementaires
ce qui est certain c'est que cette loi
elle a un objectif c'est effectivement
de pouvoir redonner un prix juste à la
production agricole
je voudrais faire une petite note dans
toutes nos lois
l'objectif c'est effectivement d'aller
au coeur aux racines des problèmes on
propose des choses des heures et des
heures de débat
mais si les débats je dire qu'ils sont
parfois théorique
notre objectif c'est que on passe de la
loi ensuite à la réalité le but c'est
pas dans des belles lois c'est de
changer la réalité
donc l'objectif qu'elle sénat d'évaluer
la mise en oeuvre de la loi
c'est aussi le nôtre le but c'est que
sur le terrain dans les différentes
filières on a eu à observer ce qui se
passe qu'on regarde comment les
négociations se passent et que dans un
an dans deux ans on puisse dire voilà on
avait une oie on avait ces objectifs là
qu'est ce que ça apporte et qu'est ce
que ça a changé et ce qui est des choses
à ajuster et ce qu'il faut que la loi y
plus loin est-ce qu'il faut que le poids
politique revienne pour que et bien les
objectifs soient remplis
je trouve ça très sain et je pense que
parfois dans ce pays on passe beaucoup
trop de temps à fignoler la loi à
rentrer dans des discours politiciens et
pas du tout à ces temps de passer des
lois la réalité est d'évaluer la réalité
ce combat l'évaluation je pense que
c'est un très bon combat des
parlementaires c'est notre rôle c'est ce
que dit la constitution sur notre rôle
et j'aimerais qu'on y passe autant de
temps qu'on vient de passer la de débat
à savoir si la cmp est exclusivement
pour finir un mot sur une autre loi
qu'il faudra sans doute évalue elle a
été adoptée à l'assemblée cette semaine
la loi relative à la lutte contre la
fraude a été voté par 4 117 voix pour 36
voix contre elle a reçu l'appui des
députés la république en marché du
modèle mais aussi des républicains de
lui dit agir et des socialistes les
insoumis et les communistes ont voté
contre dénonçant des demi-mesures à
millemont chars ainsi que la fraude
représente un manque à gagner énorme 40
60 80 milliards 100 milliards dit
certains quelle est la part de cet
immense pactole que cette loi devrait
permettre de récupérer en fait elle va
aussi à la racine des choses donc on
créer une police fiscale
on a enfin réussi à déverrouiller fameux
verrou
merci qui était un outil qui était vu
par certains comme une limite à la
poursuite
on a aussi beaucoup de moyens qui sont
données en termes d'investissements
notamment pour avoir des données pour
que l'état soit à peu près aussi
puissants que ceux qui bavent fraude
cette loi est extrêmement importante
parce qu'elle montre bien que ça on
avait fait le droit à l'erreur pour que
caen de bonne foi une personne n'arrive
pas à bien remplir son formulaire bien
le monde ne s'arrête pas et là on a
vraiment le levier pénale le levier des
moyens et des leviers a surtout pour que
et bien les agents qui contrôle cette
fraude soit aussi équipé que ceux qui
fraudent cette loi elle est aussi
extrêmement importante parce que elle
est le fruit d'un bon travail
parlementaire ce résultat de 97 4 197
voix pour c'est parce que emilie cariou
la rapporteure et puis l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui ont travaillé sur ce
texte l'ont fait de manière transparente
is a donc fait de manière vraiment
précises ils ont pris du temps et ils
ont réussi à débloquer des sujets sur
lequel tout le monde tournait autour du
pot depuis des années charles de courson
qui est un député expérimenté notre
assemblée a dit que ça faisait 25 ans
qui se battaient pour le verrou de bercy
soit supprimé il a été supprimé là parce
que justement à la méthode pour y
revenir en a parlé avant c'est un
travail qui a été mené de manière
extrêmement ouverte transparente et tout
ce qui a été fait de manière
transparente isana pu être conservé il
ya aussi dans cette tête dans ce texte
des choses sur la convergence européenne
sur la liste des paradis fiscaux
la liste des paradis fiscaux est assez
réduite dans le texte enfin certains
l'ont critiqué alors on prend la liste
européenne et on y met des sanctions on
est le premier pays européen à avoir
pris d'abord la liste européenne parce
que la liste européenne pour l'instant
c'était une liste un peu qu'ils aient
joly qui était un peu décoratives donc
là et maintenant et rendent dans
d'autres endroits et surtout on y à la
sortie des sanctions on est le premier
pays européen à le faire aujourd'hui
notre volonté est totale et surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on y met
des moyens les moyens humains des moyens
de recherche des moyens de donner
on a aussi regardé des chaussures les
plateformes bref on s'est donné tout un
attirail de mesures est là aussi
l'évaluation est clé pour que la loi
devienne réalité
allez le voilà pour la loi contre la
fraude une rapide question politique
pour pour finir j le jean le nouveau
président du groupe la république en
marche a annoncé qu'il souhaitait nommer
une vice-présidente une première
vice-présidente une femme ce sera vous
nous sommes plusieurs à être candidate
et donc je pense que gilles levrand
présidence fera son choix
effectivement dans ce groupe vous savez
un mot paritaire c'est la première fois
de l'histoire qu'un groupe majoritaire
et paritaire et bien les femmes que nous
sommes nous travaillons nous souhaitons
avoir
du poids politique et donc que nous
avons été un certain nombre à être
candidate et nous verrons ça dans les
prochains jours merci beaucoup
mais dimanche à mains d'avoir été notre
invité cette semaine merci thibault et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau résumé de l'actualité
parlementaire
[Musique]